تشهد شوارع العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس
مواجهات بين الشرطه والمحتاجين على خلفيه
رفع سن التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما
حيث تقدر النقابات عدد المحتجين على قانون
التقاعد بنحو 400 الف في باريس وحده ودعا
هنا الفرنسيون الى الاضراب والتظاهر ضد
اصلاح نظام التقاعد الذي يعد الثاني عشر
في ثلاثه اشهر عشيه طبعا قرار حاسم للمجلس
الدستوري بشان هذا المشروع من هولندا اكد
مقهوم بان هذا القرار يمكن ان يغلق طريقا
ويوضح كل الاسئله المطروحه قبل ان يعلن
انه سيقترح بروح توافقيه لقاء مع الشركاء
الاجتماعيين يذكر انه منذ بدايه الازمه
يراوح الحوار مع النقابات مكانه هو جرت
المحادثات في اجواء من التوتر في الاسابيع
الاخيره بين كل من رئيس الدوله وقاده
النقابات لاسيما رئيس الاتحاد الديمقراطيه
الفرنسي للعمل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات